let's go next to our caller from the
6:01 area code who's calling today from
6:01 hello David yes who's this uh hey
my name is Houston
alright Houston what's going on Houston
in Mississippi I love it I had a
question kind of regarding the
governor's race and more local politics
in general Mississippi has a very unique
system of how we elect our governor and
it's we have districts and to win the
governor's seat you have to get more
than 50% of the vote overall but also
you have to win districts right it's not
like total college system but worse and
if no candidate wins both 50% or all the
districts
then representatives of the house just
decide to the governor is out of the top
two indeed and my question really comes
into count is any progressive fight in a
system like that
but any change where it feels like
there's just a wall of dissident print
disenfranchisement sorry it's really
cold out here yeah well so listen you
did this is why local politics matters
you have to elect candidates who say
that they will lobby to change that and
of course the this is the fundamental
difficulty with a lot of the systems
that we have the system is set up to
reinforce the status quo that elects the
people that are there it's sort of like
with term limits term limits excuse me
or campaign finance are the elected
officials that were elected by the
campaign finance system we have going to
be motivated to do away with that system
only the most principled minority is
going to do that sadly so it's the same
type of thing with the Mississippi
system you need to start electing people
to the legislature who say that they
will Lobby to have that chain
and have a governor that's willing to go
along with it but that's the system that
got them there so why would they do that
yeah yeah it's a bit of a it's a bit of
a dream killer of a system but guess
that's why we keep finding absolutely
all right thank you so much for the call
it's windy there so I'm gonna let you go
I hope it's not so strong that that it's
causing you a problem getting around but
thank you for the call